KAREN: So what does it mean
to be truly authentic,
and how does this idea
of authenticity impact
what it means to be
whole or personhood?
And so, like, looking at
yourself, how do you identify,
and how is your identity
your chosen identity
based on your conceptualization
of what it means
to be authentically something?
Does, like, how you
define authenticity
and your relationship to
authenticity impact how
you choose to identify?
RACHEL: And sort of as an extension
of this-- and these kind of
go together.
That's why we're
saying them together.
Do the languages, or does
the language that you speak,
or that your
ancestors spoke affect
this concept of authenticity?
So if you're the son of someone
whose parents spoke a language,
but you don't speak it, do
you feel less authentic,
or does it make you feel more
authentic in some manner?
Or are there linguistic
discourses of power
that affect how you
perceive the roles
that the languages that you
speak or that of your ancestors
spoke affect your
choice of identity--
and how authenticity of my
language plays a role in it?
KAREN: Should we present
the second question?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: I think we
should start answering, right?
So thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: I guess I don't
mind answering first.
So I guess the first thing--
so I'll answer one and two,
but I'll start with two,
because this is something
that I always think about--
is the fact that I don't speak
Spanish makes me less authentic
in whatever Hispanic or
Mexican identity I have,
because I'm not able--
I feel like I wasn't
allowed to identify
with the Hispanic or
Mexican community,
because I didn't speak Spanish.
And like, you
know, growing up, I
guess it was different
for my mother.
It didn't matter to her, and
I guess at that timeframe,
you know, whatever
the population-- like,
Spanish is becoming a very
profound language in the US,
and so, like, maybe
during my mother's time
there weren't a whole lot
of Spanish speakers, so,
like, for her, it didn't matter.
And like, my
grandmother growing up,
it was, like, not
OK for her to speak,
and so I feel like it's
different for my mother
because she doesn't care.
Honestly, I don't know how
I should ask my mom how
she identifies with herself,
but it's very different
because, for me, I do feel like
that was important whereas it
wasn't important for her.
And I still don't feel authentic
in my Hispanic or Mexican
identity, because I don't
speak the language--
and that maybe, in some
ways, speaking the language
would allow me to
identify more with,
like, the culture, because
I feel like it's important.
And then I guess,
overall, authentic,
I honestly hate thinking
of it like that,
because I am so
un-authentic then,
because I'm African-American,
I'm white, and I'm Hispanic,
and nobody considers me
authentic because it's like,
how can you be
authentic if being--
I feel like being
authentic, in this way,
means, like, having to
identify specifically
with one or another, and you
can't authentically be all--
you can't be more than one.
I don't know if
that makes sense.
And I guess for me, it's
just like my identity,
I just have to pick and choose
what I liked, what was OK,
and some of it has
been imposed on me.
There are aspects of my identity
that I didn't get to choose
and that I'm trying to change,
because like now feeling woke,
I guess, and learning about
different aspects of my culture
and history regarding
whatever it may be,
I feel like I'm trying to
change aspects of my identity
that were not--
yeah, I hope those
answered your questions.
I got really flustered, because
there's this camera over here.
Normally, it wouldn't
matter, but yeah--
so I hope that
answers your question.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So let me make a
note-- let me make a note here,
because I think you've
mentioned the camera.
But this is not live,
which means that--
AUDIENCE: It doesn't matter.
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
No, with whatever
you decide that you don't want
to be going to the billions
will be moved, OK?
AUDIENCE: No, I
wouldn't do that.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, so I want
you to feel totally comfortable
that if you say
anything that you feel
should stay in the class here--
I think it's OK.
We'll just-- we'll just
edit it and make sure that--
AUDIENCE: No, it's
not that about.
It's just--
AUDIENCE: Beyond having it, OK.
AUDIENCE: It's the
idea somebody out
there would end up watching
and listening to what I say.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: But
one thing that you
have to think about, too--
I mean, which is
actually key, so there
are lots of other folks, you
know, even younger than you.
At least, you can step
back, and as you've just
said-- you said, OK, now
I need to remove that
from my identity.
I need to make this choice.
I need to think about what
was imposed to myself.
We see that-- how many people
don't have this capacity
to actually step back and self
analyze the way you just did,
you see?
AUDIENCE: I like
to analyze myself.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah,
but that's something
that you're sharing
with other people that
might help them a lot, you
know, because it frees you
to be able to do that, right?
AUDIENCE: Sometimes.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: It's a
path to freedom in a way--
self-liberation, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think I also feel
constraining at the same time,
because it's so hard to--
because I think like some
of the things-- like,
some of these things are
so ingrained into society
and for different people--
like, how you see
yourself in the world.
And it's really hard
to change perception.
For instance, I have talked
about this, but like,
hair, African-American
hair, and trying
to change my perception
of African-American hair
relates in some ways to changing
perceptions of my own identity
because they're related,
if that makes sense?
Yeah, other people can--
AUDIENCE: I guess I don't know.
I think it's, like, kind
of unfair not for you guys
because we all do it, but
it's unfair to to use the word
authentic when referring
to something like identity,
or culture, or a group of
people, because it's like--
I mean, I don't think
it was a word that
was intended for a person.
It's very much like one
of those adjectives that's
for inanimate objects, you know?
It's like for things
that don't have--
AUDIENCE: Gold.
AUDIENCE: Yeah like gold,
like authentic, like something
that you can define.
Like, OK, if something's
authentically gold,
that means it's 100% gold.
But you can't put
bounds on things
like people, and cultures,
and identities to the point
where you have a
concrete definition,
because no person's ever going
to get that perfect definition.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: But it has
always been the tendency
to try to quantize these--
so you mentioned gold, right.
So in the history of Haiti,
there was this famous French--
she was Creole French,
meaning that she
was of French ancestry, but
he was born in the Caribbean.
His name was [INAUDIBLE],, and
he added one chapter where he
created this calculus of--
he could compute 128 parts
of black versus white.
So he had this calculus of if
you half black, half white,
then you're mulatto.
If you're quarter black
with three quarters white,
then you're Quadroon.
And he had terms.
He had adjectives--
talking about adjectives--
he had adjectivves for
each of these categories,
but how do you compute that?
How can you look at someone and
decide that they are 128 black
versus the rest, white?
But there was this
strong belief somebody
that you could do
that, and that actually
each of these
partitions would define
[INAUDIBLE] biological reasons.
But if you were half
black, half white,
you would behave
like this, or you
would have physical
properties from these lines.
But if you were one quarter
white and three quarters black,
then you could predict what
your behavior and your physique
would actually look like.
Think of Jim Crow in the US,
so one drop of black blood--
one drop of black blood would
make you non-white, right?
But it's good to have people
to think of it in these terms
and try to remove ourself
from this cognition.
AUDIENCE: So I guess what
I'm thinking about is--
I remember you told this story
early in the semester about
how there are these
documentarians from New
York who came to do
interviews with you--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That's right.
I was thinking of that, yeah.
AUDIENCE: --and they
felt bad because the idea
that, like, they were
less Haitian for not
speaking Haitian creole.
So I agree that the
idea of authenticity
implies that there is
this paradigm-like way
to be an identity,
but so I don't know.
Like, it's not clear to me--
it seems possible that, like,
the paradigm Haitian does speak
Creole, though I don't know.
I wonder about that.
AUDIENCE: I also feel like that
I agree with that statement.
However I feel that
maybe in the future
it won't be a possible paradigm
just because of migration
and the fact that there can
be a Haitian who is, like,
three generations away from
that parent that was Haitian,
and they're still allowed
to say that they're Haitian.
They don't speak Creole.
They may be, I don't know,
have whatever you can
define as the paradigm Haitian.
So I guess for now that
might be a true statement
to a certain extent,
but I don't think that--
but I think that that was the
point of the concept of us
and authenticity.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: And we still got
to mention Achebe and Wachongo,
right, because they had the
whole debate about what's
authentic African rights, right?
And that was actually
part of bigger constraints
where they were debating
what makes them authentic.
AUDIENCE: Yeah. but the problem
is like the line drawing.
Like, oh, you're
not a real Haitian.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I guess one
thing I could add here
is like, a lot of your examples
were, like, mixing authenticity
for, like, different
cultures and that
not being authentic any more.
But one thing I really liked
that you guys brought up
was the idea of, like, tracks--
and especially what
he said about India,
where when you think
of India, there's
this one thing you can think
of, whether it's like the food
or like the culture.
And that's like
very north Indian.
Like, I come from south India,
and if I like-- as I came here,
I chose to be more Indian.
Like, I got more involved
on clubs on campus and stuff
like that, but like--
and the Indian I'm
becoming is very
different than my
actual heritage.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I have all these
connections on like cultures
that I think I'm getting,
but it's actually not
really connected to
my family at all.
And I guess that's partially
because I don't speak
the language that they
have, so none of my culture
came from, like,
my family really.
But also by not speaking that
language, like, everything
about my culture from
home whether it's
religion or anything
like that, it's
kind of very separated from me.
So I guess I kind
of understand it,
but I don't really understand
the roots of most of it.
Whereas everything here that
I'm leaning, I'm like, oh, OK.
Like, this makes sense, and
this is what everyone does.
I mean, to be like
an Indian in America.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK.
So I think that that goes
back to your question,
because if you
think of who is now
one of the best known Haitian
writers, Edwidge Danticat,
that we've read in this
class, and in which--
OK, she was in Haiti until
age 12, and then at age 12,
she came to Brooklyn,
New York, and now she's
one of the best Haitian writers.
And she sees herself
as Haitian, you see?
And she speaks Creole, but
she doesn't write in Creole.
All of the text that she
has become famous for,
they are English texts.
But for me, when I
read Edwidge Danticat,
as we did here in the
class, I hear Haiti,
I see Haiti, I feel
Haiti, because she's
managed to write as a
Haitian although she
didn't speak Creole.
And as she does, she's also
become a very powerful woman.
Another case is
Wyclef Jean, right?
You guys know this hip
hop artist, Wyclef?
So Wyclef has done
so much for Haiti.
In fact, at some point, even
was to be Haitian president,
and he was--
actually, that's a
good story, because he
was excluded from running
because he was not
Haitian enough legally.
He had spent too much
time out of Haiti.
But yet, he's one of the best
known Haitians in the world
today, Wyclef Jean, because
a major hip hop artist,
and he sings mostly in
English, but he also
has some songs in Creole
actually to remind people
that he is Haitian.
And always, when he sings--
when he goes to a concert,
he wrap himself up
with the Haitian flag,
so he's very pro-Haitian without
having the full inventory
of what defines Haitianes
So I think I like watching this
person show's-- the idea that
you can create your own
identity even in America,
and that's what an
identity should do for it.
It should be an asset.
It should be a tool for us
[INAUDIBLE] the world, not
something that we
need to hold as fact.
And if you look at the
literature on stereotype
threat, that's the
way it was actually,
so people were being hindered
in their performance because
of identity.
It was because of them being
put in a box because of that.
You see what you guys all
think that, well, we can use it
in a way, like what you said,
it would me to create my own
and be powerful with it
and be happy with it.
You see, now, it's other
people who put me in the box.
And I think that's what we
should think about when people
are imposing on us
to actually described
as moving between
imposed identities
that they want to pull
yourself away from,
and eventually if you do
that, well, you become
happier, right, hopefully?
AUDIENCE: Hopefully.